hello and welcome back to what i guess
i'm going to call our interlude between
chapter 1 and chapter 2 since i've
started recording our first batch of
videos a number of things have changed
and so i just want to touch on those
before we get into chapter 2 the first
and most obvious thing you'll notice is
that i'm now using Xcode 5 and my guess
is you're going to be using it to and
for most of the stuff moving forward I'm
going to be testing on iOS 7 devices so
that's the first and biggest change the
second is that we've upgraded both the
Google+ and the google play games SDKs
since we first launched these videos in
Google+ land we are now using SDK
version 1.4 and on google play games
we're now using version 1.2 if you've
used old versions of either of these
libraries you're going to need to
download the new versions of these
libraries and install them and actually
need to do that here so I'm going to
show you how I do it it turns out that
at least in my case upgrading frameworks
and bundles with in Xcode is a it causes
some issues for me I've never had good
luck with this xcode suddenly seems to
you know forget what my GP g manager is
and can't seem to find it and you know i
run into a lot of odd issues and as
counterintuitive as it might seem I've
actually had much better luck if I
update these frameworks just using
finder so I'm going to do that so first
thing we're going to do I'm going to
close this project next code next up I'm
going to open up a finder window when my
project is located and now i'm going to
download the updated version of each of
these libraries so let me open up chrome
here and first I'm going to go to
developers.google.com/live services /
downloads by the time you see this video
this should now say games SDK version 12
or maybe one to one and click on this
link to download it and then you can go
to developers.googl calm + / downloads
to download the updated version of the
Google+ SDK for iOS and I'm going to
download it here and you can see it's
telling me I have SDK version one for
one so now I'm going to go into my
downloads folder and here we can see the
new SDKs let's extract the zip and this
will probably say 12 not one to beta and
now we can replace the frameworks so
here's what I'm going to do it's pretty
straightforward first let's do the
Google+ SDK so I'm going to go into my
guess my number folder or wherever it
turns out xcode has copied the framework
folders for you in my case that's right
in here I'm going to delete these two
frameworks there we go just the two
frameworks and I'm going to copy them
over again with in finder into the same
location and then I'm going to do the
same thing with my Play game services
framework and bundle delete it and then
copy these two over there we go again I
know this seems a little
counterintuitive we're sort of swapping
out frameworks kind of under the feet of
Xcode and it doesn't seem to know that
it's happening but if you open up this
project again in Xcode it seems to
handle these changes pretty elegantly
which is nice now once that's done if
you try to compile this thing you'll
probably get a number of errors yep it
looks like it's you know stuff that
looks like this and that's because the
new Google+ SDK requires four more
frameworks for us to add so we'll go
into these and so first thing we're
going to add is core motion there we go
we're also going to add core location
next we're going to add assets library
and finally we're going to add media
player all right once those four new
frameworks have been added the SDK
should compile correctly let's run it
see what happens no issues build
succeeded that's good and there we go
everything seems to be working although
you might notice an odd little error
which is that our title has now
disappeared underneath this navigation
controller and in fact if i click easy
to go into an easy game you'll see that
you know the instructions i can't really
see because it's hidden behind this
somewhat translucent navigation
controller now this is happening because
well i do not follow recommended
protocol and start using auto layout
when it first became available and you
know right now somebody in cupertino is
laughing at me saying yeah you thought
you were so smart ignoring or
recommendations but but who's laughing
now huh tough guy so if you're using
auto layout this probably doesn't happen
to you in my situation there does happen
to be a pretty easy way to fix it and
that involves using these new iOS 6 7
Delta's that you see right here so
here's what we're going to do here's how
this works I am going to switch over to
my file inspector and I'm going to say I
want to view this nib as an iOS 6 dot
one layout everything's looking good so
far and now I want to select this label
and these three buttons go back to the
size inspector and here I'm going to set
the Delta Y to 60 and that means place
these objects here for now and iOS 6 but
when you switch to iOS 7 move them down
by about 60 points hit return and now
when I run this will see that in iOS 7
the guess my number label as well as
these buttons have now been moved down
underneath the navigation controller bar
here and if I were to run this in iOS 6
they're still back in their original
location so this is one workaround if
you find yourself running into the same
issues once you've switched to iOS 7 and
that we can do the same thing in the
game view controller here i'm going to
select actually just about everything
here make sure i'm viewing it as iOS 6
dot 1 and then go back to my size
inspector and South the Delta Y to 60
and that will have this one fixed as
well so I go back to iOS 7 and run this
everything is now placed properly on an
iOS 7 device and so with that we are now
fully modernized we're using Xcode 5 iOS
7 using version 1 dot 4 of the Google+
SDK or I guess 14 not one and using
version 12 of the play games SDK and who
knows maybe by the time you see this
video will even be at a higher version
but there you go with that we're now all
set to go and we can start looking at
achievements which we'll do in the next
lesson
haha